stell dir vor du beginnst das stellwerk
eine straßenbahn
es ist dein job tag für tag
reine routine
heute aber hast du ein problem der
wagenführer kann ich bremsen die bahn
rollt geradewegs auf 5 fleißarbeit dazu
die davon nichts hören und sehen
wenn du nicht tust sterben alle fünf
arbeiter du kannst die weiche stelle
aber auf dem anderen gleis steht auch
ein arbeiter ein einzelner in diesem
augenblick bist du die einsamste person
auf dem planeten
du hast die verantwortung was tust du
unternimmt du nichts und überlässt die
fünf arbeiter ihrem schicksal oder
opfers du den feinen und rät es damit
fünf menschenleben
wenn dir diese entscheidung schon schwer
fällt
dabei setzen wir noch einen drauf
angenommen du stehst auf einer brücke
den fünf gleisarbeitern donnert wieder
die straßenbahn entgegen weichen kannst
du diesmal keine stellen es gibt nur
eine chance und die sitzt direkt neben
dir seine masse würde den zug zum stehen
bringen und die fünf retten
er selbst würde dabei jedoch sterben das
resultat ist dasselbe du rettest fünf
leben und opferst 1 was ist richtig und
lassen sich menschen leben überhaupt
gegeneinander abwägen